[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von 485
köpfe fünf meinungen seit acht tagen
wütet putins krieg mehr als eine million
ukraine sind auf der flucht und der
ukrainische präsident seelands gefordert
zeigt dass er ein bündnis seit braucht
es einen putsch gegen putin warum gerade
die nato nicht in der ukraine krieg ein
was tut das verteidigungsbündnis aktuell
und braucht deutschland jetzt das
gesellschafts jahr für junge menschen
darüber möchte ich mit meinem heutigen
gästen diskutieren der ukrainische
botschafter anderem eine cdu politiker
christoph ploß an meiner seite der
stellvertretende bild chefredakteur er
ist noch nicht da aber dafür ist peter
hell schon da der ist uns auch
zugeschaltet aus der ukraine hallo peter
schön dass du dabei bist paul folgt
später
genau und dann haben wir noch last but
not least denn wenn ich jetzt natürlich
nicht vergessen unseren kulturen ist
hans ulrich jörges lassen sie uns keine
zeit verlieren lassen sie uns direkt mal
fragen bei peter hell peter du bist mal
in ukraine wo bist du du hast hier
verlassen wie war die route aus kehrt
raus und wie ist die lage aktuell der
ukraine
also ich fange mal an wo wir sind und
ich möchte erstmal um verzerrungen bei
der botschaft dass über eine aussprache
sind - prof das ist richtig
ausgesprochen wir sind gestern aus kiew
raus in den frühen morgenstunden
es war gespenstisch muss ich sagen da
um 7 uhr haben derart fahrt gehabt durch
eine geisterstadt gefahren an mehreren
checkpoints vorbei man aktiv ist in
einem kompletten
schockzustand nachts die bombardements
dauernd kriegen die sie reden auf den
straßen sind keine menschen es ist eine
gespenstische ruhe die sich da durch
diese engen straßen ziehen checkpoints
überall also man wartet im prinzip auf
dem
feuersturm der hoffentlich nie eintreten
wird aber wir befürchten schlimmstes
bisschen raus und wir sind dann in eine
statt ausfahrt gekommen wo man gemerkt
hat okay hier bereitet man sich auf das
schlimmste vor ist werden gräben
ausgehoben es werden
[Musik]
später wir haben gerade ein wenig
verbindungsschwierigkeiten würde direkt
herr wenig fragen wie seiner
einschätzung auch ist wie es gerade um
die ukraine steht
also die lage ist in der tat immer
dramatischer mit mit jedem mit jedem tag
für die menschen und zwar nicht nur in
der hauptstadt sondern auch vor allem im
osten im
nordosten aber auch im süden da wo die
russen im moment ziemlich weit
vordringen konnten
und das schlimmste ist dass die menschen
dass die menschen
nicht nur die soldaten aber vor allem
die menschen zerbombt werden und dass
sie jetzt
zu geiseln genommen werden von von
diesen vorrückenden truppen aber auf
allem von den raketenwerfern und von der
luftwaffe denn die die die tödlichsten
stöße die kommen vom vom himmel und das
ist natürlich das schlimmste an diesem
an diesem krieg das dass die zivilisten
die ersten opfer dieses
vernichtungskrieges geworden sind und
deswegen haben wir schon seit dem essen
tag seit acht tagen fordern wir von
unseren partnern in der nato eine no fly
zone zu errichten der mitte zumindest
die zivilisten in schutz genommen werden
können und der mitte auch atomkraftwerke
heute ist das größte atomkraftwerk in
europa in der stadt ernähren da wurde
auch von den russischen truppen
vorläufig übersetzt ist nicht mehr unter
unserer kontrolle was geschieht da das
heißt da müssen muss sie jetzt
nachgedacht werden natürlich wollen wir
nicht dass die nato jetzt in diesen
krieg dann steigt das ist ein richtig
gefahr ist da aber es muss eine kreative
lösung gefunden werden wie man wie man
dieses morden vom himmel verhindert auch
der ukrainische präsident finanz gehört
heute auf einer geheim- pressekonferenz
gesprochen points hammer ist jetzt auch
bei uns im studio zumindest digital ist
er ab jetzt auch die ganze sendung dabei
ich sehe ihn hier neben mir und deswegen
vielen herzlichen dank an peter helfe
die einschätzung und jetzt möchten wir
natürlich auch direkt die einschätzung
von paul ronzheimer hören und paul
erzähle uns doch bitte von dem was sie
lenski heute in der geheim-
pressekonferenz gesagt hat
janina es war sicherlich eine der
ungewöhnlichsten begegnungen die ich
jemals in kiew hatte und zwar deshalb
weil ich schon häufig in diesem
präsidenten gebäude war 2014 häufig
petro poroschenko interviewt ab dann sie
lenski bereits interviewt ab aber als
ich dort heute hin kam mit wahnsinnigen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen und dann in
dieses präsidenten gebäude gegangen bin
war das licht ausgeschaltet man ist fast
über die treppen gestolpert weil zu
dunkel war dann lagen sandsäcke überall
das muss man sich so ein bisschen
vorstellen als würde im kanzleramt
plötzlich kein licht mehr scheinen und
olaf scholz sich irgendwo verstecken und
auf geheime wege werden dort
journalisten reingebracht damit es eine
kriegs pressekonferenz geben könnte das
war so ein fall dann saßen die
journalisten einzelne eingeladene
journalisten in diesem raum der wiederum
relativ normal aussah dann kam sie
lenski dort rein und er machte einen
trotz dieses krieges trotz dieser
persönlichen bedrohung auch für ihn
selbst denn er steht ja auf einer
todesliste ganz weit oben an platz eins
wahrscheinlich von wladimir putin haben
sich einen stuhl und hat sich direkt vor
die journalisten gesetzt er weiß
natürlich wie inszenierung funktioniert
als ehemaliger schauspieler auch als
präsident mittlerweile weiß er dass wie
man mit bildern umgeht aber es war so
einen unterschied zu den bildern die man
von wladimir putin kennt auch die
pressekonferenz oder die ansprache die
putin vor hingehalten hat wo er wieder
gedroht hat und gesagt hat der krieg
geht weiter wo er gesagt hat dass er die
ukraine hat für nazis hält und deswegen
die russen und ukrainer vereint werden
müssten und die nazis bekämpft werden
müssen diese absurde schwachsinn ist zu
nett ausgedrückt diese grauenhaften
lügen die wladimir putin über die
ukraine verbreitet und dagegen wie lenz
geht er mir gegenüber saß und wir kennen
uns von früheren interviews und ich habe
ihn dann gefragt hey yo und seelands
gerhard nur gesagt und hat mir die hand
gereicht und wir haben kurz die hände
geschüttelt und man erlebt einen
präsidenten der wirklich über sich
hinauswächst und er hat dann wieder sehr
klar adressiert was notwendig ist aus
seiner sicht er hat klar gemacht dass
das land kämpfen wir dass sie nicht
aufgeben werden er hat gesagt wenn er
nicht präsident wäre dann wäre er auch
in einer zivilen verteidigungs einheit
er hat gesagt dass er unterstützung will
eine no fly so und sicherlich eine
unrealistische forderung dennoch hat er
das klar gemacht und er hat einen satz
gesagt den ich ja sehr wichtig finde
vielleicht auch jetzt hier für die
diskussion er hat gesagt wenn putin dort
nicht gestoppt wird wenn es nicht
geschafft wird putin in der ukraine zu
stoppen dann sind die nächsten länder
die baltischen staaten und irgendwann
steht putin dann in berlin er hat gesagt
er stünde dann würde bis zur berliner
mauer gehen also er meint sozusagen das
ehemalige ost berlin das sind dinge die
vor monaten janisch andere politiker
gesagt haben aber nena nachdem all das
wahr geworden ist was ja die größten
pessimisten wie wir vielleicht und
andere angenommen haben was putin machen
würde hört man ganz genau hin wenn dann
diese sätze kommen
das kann ich mir absolut vorstellen paul
und es ist also ich weiß gar nicht was
man dabei empfindet wenn man zu so einer
geheim- pressekonferenz geht
christoph das alles auch sehr wahl in
ukraine konflikt dass das paar gerade
erklärt hat wir haben gerade über die no
fly sohn gesprochen sollten wir die
umsetzen dass man da etwas heikle frage
weil es auch öl ins feuer gießen kann
aber ich kann die argumente des herrn
botschafters sehr gut nachvollziehen
weil die russen ja nicht nur
militärische angriffe verüben wie sie
selber in ihrer propaganda behaupten
sondern leider auch sehr viele angriffe
auf zivilisten
vornehmen krankenhäuser mittlerweile
bombardieren ganz normale wohnhäuser
unschuldige menschen und dieses treiben
was putin da mittlerweile seit gut einer
woche macht diesen treiben kann man
nicht zu sehen deswegen halte ich schon
für notwendig dass wir dieses thema auch
stärker hier in den fokus der deutschen
und europäischen politik nehmen aber es
ist eine schwierige abwägung das muss
man auch klar sagen weil putin ja
mittlerweile auch sogar mit atomaren
angriffen droht ganz bewusst auf dieses
schreckensszenario aufbaut und wir alle
wissen noch aus der zeit des kalten
krieges wenn einer meint falschen knopf
drückt oder irgendwo was ausrutscht dann
kann es ganz schnell zu einer großen
katastrophe führen deswegen ist im
moment das wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
auch die richtigen entscheidungen zu
treffen ich wollte noch einmal auch paul
ronzheimer fragen der da wirklich im
moment
im wahrsten sinne des wortes an der
front steht und auch wirklich
hervorragenden journalismus macht ganz
live dabei ist ich hoffe auch dass er
dafür einen reporter preis und
journalisten preis bekommt das hat er
auf jeden fall verdient aber mich würde
mal interessieren
was die ukraine weiter an waffen braucht
oder wie sich das auch in den nächsten
tagen möglicherweise entwickeln könnte
denn als vor gut einer woche putin mit
dem angriff begonnen hat da haben in
deutschland ja sehr viele gesagt
defensivwaffen an die ukraine zu liefern
das bringt ja gar nichts mehr weil das
sowieso nach zwei oder drei tagen alles
vorbei ist und jetzt sehen wir die
ukraine die haben haben da wirklich an
hilft heroischen kampf die kämpfen wie
die besten die machen das super und es
gibt ganz für unterstützung auch aus der
welt und mittlerweile ja auch die
hoffnung dass die ukraine den kampf
vielleicht sogar gewinnen können was man
von einer woche nie gedacht hätte
inwiefern würden weitere defensiv
waffenlieferungen helfen das würde mich
noch mal interessieren weil das ja auch
für die entscheidung hier in deutschland
von großer bedeutung ist
der applaus nicht ob sie sprechen da
einen sehr wichtigen punkt an und
zunächst einmal muss man sagen das
glaube ich ganz viele politiker zum
beispiel strack zimmermann von der fdp
und andere die gesagt haben und in einer
zynischen art und weise gesagt haben
naja jetzt ist das ja so und die russen
haben eben eine militärische übermacht
und was sollen wir denn noch hin liefern
ich glaube diese politiker die sollten
sich ganz dringend bei andrej melik dem
ukrainischen botschafter entschuldigen
und frau strack zimmermann ist da nicht
die erste nicht die einzige da können
noch ganz viele dazu kommen auch von
ihrer partei und von der spd die sollten
gesammelt dort bei der botschaft
vorstellig werden bei allmählich und
sich entschuldigen bei ihm denn erst der
mann der über monate lang immer wieder
gesagt hat wir brauchen diese waffen
laut und deutlich hat er das gesagt
niemand wollte ihm zu hören niemand aus
dieser politik hat ihn wirklich ernst
genommen niemand hat sich dem angenommen
und das ist für mich eigentlich ein
skandal denn noch aufgearbeitet werden
muss aber jetzt ist es so wie es ist und
was gut ist muss man sagen ist das
wieder waffen gekommen sind aus
deutschland und wo geht es vor allem das
muss man den zuschauern auch erklärt es
geht vor allem um die abwehr von raketen
die abwehr von marschflugkörpern es geht
um flugabwehr das ist ja etwas was putin
bislang zumindest in kiew noch nicht
eingesetzt hat er hat ja alle
möglichkeiten aus der luft hier so zu
bombardieren wie er zb aleppo
bombardiert hat und dann kann ich ihnen
sagen bleibt von dieser stadt nichts
mehr übrig dann wäre hier alles schutt
und asche und dann reden wir über
zehntausende und hunderttausende tote
ich wollte was einwänden gegen den
begriff der defensivwaffen dann kann ich
nicht mehr hören die gefahr ist doch
nicht dass die ukraine russland an
greift also dass man sich also auf
kleinwaffen beschränken muss die ukraine
muss möglichst wirkungsvoll bewaffnet
werden und elias bei einer
flugverbotszone zu luft kämpfen zwischen
nato flugzeugen und russischen
flugzeugen kommen lassen das wäre der
gang in den in den atomaren krieg glaube
ich in einer riesen eskalation muss die
ukraine in die lage versetzt werden
durch moderne waffensysteme nicht nur
durch schulter gestützte
kleinraketen die auf flugzeuge
abgeschlossen werden soll natürlich
richtige wirkungsvolle luftabwehr
batterien sich zur wehr zu setzen und
die müssen natürlich an allen größeren
städten seien und es wird höchste zeit
dass die geliefert werden ob die
ursprünglich für defensive oder
offensive aufgaben gedacht sind ist mir
völlig wurscht sie müssen wirken und ich
möchte den begriff von defensivwaffen
nicht mehr hören die ukraine wird
russland die angreifen
wenig es ist auch ihre meinung jetzt so
wir haben gerade vor dieser sendung habe
ich eine lange lange liste eine neue
liste von den waffensystemen die wir
gerade jetzt brauchen an das
verteidigungsministerium und an das
auswärtige amt geschickt und da ist die
frage von defensiv oder offensiv waffen
nicht so relevant wir verteidigen uns
seit acht tagen wir sind auf unserem
boden wir haben nicht vor jemanden
anzugreifen und auch nicht vor die
gebiete die bereits vor diesem angriff
besetzt waren von russen die creme und
donners auch nicht zurück erlauben mit
den waffen aber was wir wollen wir
wollen das leben der zivilisten schützen
wir wollen
wir wollen die systeme zum beispiel
bachelot oder ketten also die die hat
man hier in deutschland wir werden jetzt
auch ins baltikum versetzt das braucht
man auch um die verbündeten zu schützen
aber vielleicht gibt es auch eine
überlegung etwas was kommt als erstes
also wir sind jetzt schon angegriffen
worden und das heißt dann müssen wir
nicht nur jetzt die vielleicht so sehr
die bundeswehr oder das
verteidigungsministerium in pflicht
nehmen sondern auch die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie
wir führen jetzt gespräche war es dann
auch geliefert werden kann kurzfristig
um um die menschen zu schützen aber auch
dann vielleicht auch mittelfristig um
die verteidigungsfähigkeiten zu zu
stärken in der ukraine und das werde
auch die botschaft einen putin war dann
vielleicht doch davon am sitte meine
meine lieblingsstadt werke auf meine
heimat zu zehn bomben wie alaba oder wie
andere städte die schon ihrem schicksal
liegen mussten deswegen danke für diese
unterstützung wir wir brauchen das wir
wir hoffen dass die bundesregierung sich
nicht so viel zeit nehmen wird um diese
liste zu prüfen es muss schnellstens da
geht agiert werden das heißt wir
erwarten eine antwort in den nächsten
tagen bevor ich jetzt zu meinem thema
komme weil das ist bei für den 8 gleich
geblieben dass jeder etwas mitbringt
kann was ihn aufregt habe ich noch eine
letzte frage 1 hennig und ich wünsche
mir nur einen namens hören also einen
namen eine kurze antwort herr wolf halt
eben angesprochen politiker sollten sich
bei ihnen entschuldigen wer von wem
erwarten sie denn eine entschuldung gibt
es einen politiker wo sie sagen ja das
stimmt der sollte sich wirklich mal
entschuldigen nein also ich diese
branche erwarte man keine entschuldigung
man erwartet richtiges handeln und das
ist das was ich erwarte also wir haben
über zeiten bänder jetzt alle gehörte an
diesem sonntag in der sondersitzung des
bundestages aber vier tage sind
vergangen und es ist noch bei uns
zumindest nicht angekommen ja diese
antwort herr wenig gibt es denn einen
der so richtig daneben lag wo sie sagen
also dieser politiker erhält sie sich
schon mal anders äußern können
es ist eine viel zu lange liste und die
sendung würde vielleicht zu lange dauern
weil es war dann ja nicht nur politiker
also es waren viele menschen die einfach
nicht glauben wollten auch wir wollten
nicht glauben das ist nicht so dass wir
irgendwie
apokalyptischen
bundesregierung anfangs die gesamte
regierung lag schief und das betrifft
auch die die broncos dass ich auch die
die vorherigen regierungen weil hätte
man diese schritte im jahre 14 nach der
creme aktion
eingeleitet und hätten man uns bewaffnet
dann werde es weder zum vielleicht zu
diesem krieg in diesem ausmaß gekommen
und dann glaube ich dass wir doch immer
noch in einer dringlichen ukraine leben
würden aber wie gesagt dass er schnell
von gestern heute zählt das was heute in
diesen nächsten tagen geschieht was die
regierung macht welche waffen wir
bekommen können und zwar sehr schnell
dann sehr richtig sie habe nur gesehen
die ukraine sind bereit sich zu
verteidigen das ist die große kunst
konnte sie auf mich einen guten
tradition gebrochen werden müssen wir ja
schon sagen dass die waffen hilfe aus
dem westen immer zu spät kommt immer zu
spät also immer eine phase zu spät jetzt
wo die großen städte gedrängt werden
müssten doch längst radargestützte
luftabwehrsysteme dort sein um die
städte zu verteidigen vielleicht kommen
sie irgendwann aber dann weiß ich nicht
in welchem zustand
bevor wir jetzt in die debatte gehen
schlag ich ihn jemand vorher wenig ich
finde nämlich dass dieser sich nicht nur
bei ihnen entschuldigen sollte sondern
auch bei allen deutschen ehrlich gesagt
für das was er alles so gemacht hat
zudem mehr gehalten hat und wo er so im
aufsichtsrat sitzt mein thema heute
abend ist gerhard schröder die spd
spitze hat altkanzler schröder zu recht
nämlich jetzt ein ultimatum
sein posten verzichtet gestellt spd
vorsitz den lask linker und saskia esken
haben den früheren parteichef und
bundeskanzler gerhard schröder in einem
brief ultimativ endlich in meinen augen
dazu aufgefordert seinen posten bei
russischen staatsunternehmen
niederzulegen man erwarte eine zeitnahe
antwort das hat lars klingbeil heute auf
einer gemeinsamen digitalen
pressekonferenz mit essen nach einer
sitzung des parteivorstands gesagt
sollte schröder der aufforderung die
bereits am vergangenen samstag erfolgt
seien nicht nachkommen werde man über
das weitere vorgehen beraten oder sei
zitat komplett isoliert in der
sozialdemokratie sagte klingbeil ich
kann nur sagen endlich er hat auch
gesagt im parteivorstand gebe es
niemanden mehr der schröders verhalten
auch nur ansatzweise gut heißt wo der
rechtfertigt nicht nur die spd
distanziert sich von gerhard schröder
die stadt hannover will altkanzler
gerhard schröder die ehrenbürgerwürde
entziehen ein entsprechender entschluss
der verwaltungsausschuss am
donnerstagabend einstimmig gefasst und
damit das offizielle verfahren
eingeleitet voraussichtlich am 31 märz
wird dann im rat darüber entschieden
aber ich frage mich wie lange wird
schröder diesen druck der noch
durchhalten ich nenne das verlogen es
mal klar zu sagen niemand hindert die
bundesregierung und die mehrheit im
bundestag daran ein gesetz zu erlassen
das es deutschen generell untersagt
führungspositionen in russischen
unternehmen
auszuüben das sollte längst passiert
sein da muss man nicht an schröder
appellieren dass er irgendwann von
alleine geht man muss es ihm einfach
verbieten und dann ist der fall erledigt
aber das tut natürlich deshalb keiner
weil deutschland und die bundesliga
machen ja weiterhin geschäfte mit der
gazprom sie importieren russisches gas
also wie sollen sie dann als regierung
gleichzeitig dem man verbieten bei
dergahspor funktion auszuüben ich komme
da noch drauf später die deutsche
politik ist aus meiner sicht verlogen
immer noch nicht ehrlich und das merken
wir auch am falschen
lassen sie also wir alle sollen einmal
beim fall schröder finde ich direkt
bleiben weil es alt kanzler gebieten
verbietet ja man muss hier ist vor allem
man muss hier geht hier gibt es ja vor
allem auch noch einen ganz besondern
hintergrund er ist ja nicht ein ganz
normaler bürger der keine leistungen vom
staat bekommt und irgendwie guckt wo
kann er geld verdienen dann wäre das
schon schlimm genug aber er bekommt ja
mehrere hunderttausend euro über
mitarbeiter über jedes jahr eine
entschuldung eine entlohnung bis ans
lebensende die
deutschen steuerzahler und der
hintergrund dieser entlohnung und auch
dieses mitarbeiterstabes und der
infrastruktur die er vom deutschen
steuerzahler bekommt ist ja dass er den
deutschen staat auch als altkanzler
repräsentiert so wie das viele
altkanzler und auch altbundespräsidenten
immer gemacht haben und das hat ja mit
repräsentanz nichts zu tun dass
beschädigt deutschland politisch im
ansehen in der ganzen welt und deswegen
ist es überfällig dass diese gelder vom
deutschen steuerzahler sofort
eingestellt werden bei den nächsten
haushaltsberatungen muss eines
klargestellt werden gerhard schröder
darf kein büro mehr finanziert bekommen
keine mitarbeiter mehr finanziert
bekommen und auch seine entlohnung die
er bis ans lebensende als altkanzler
eigentlich bekommt die müssten
eingestellt sei da steht ein bisschen
kopf verlassen also weiter zu dass er
bei der gas kommen und bei der rosneft
in den aufsichtsräten sitzt und neben
dem er seine kleine gelder weg wir
müssen ihm das verbieten bin sogar
überzeugen kann aber nach moskau ziehen
kann wenn ein wenn ein deutscher
staatsbürger wenn ein deutscher
staatsbürger sagt er will nach russland
ziehen und wir müssen gas zu arbeiten es
gern man das nicht was ich hier machen
da kann ja hinziehen da kann man ja
nicht verbieten
dann hat euch auch kein büro mehr genau
aber mir geht's also mir geht es ja
darum dass man sagt der deutsche
steuerzahler dass kein euro mehr an
gerhard schröder bezahlen und ausgeben
für gerhard schröders infrastruktur
anbieten und wenn wenn sie lernt
schröder stehen ein inter steht immer
noch kopf man muss verbieten dass der
mann für russland arbeitet das ist der
zentrale das können sie nämlich
wir leben ja in der community und jeder
ratssitzung kann man das beschließen
kann aber nicht und ich halte ja sogar
möglich dass er irgendwo dankbar ist
weil ihm die entscheidung abgenommen
wird er fühlt sich doch danach geht das
geht rechtlich nicht also sie könnten
heute stehen tatsächlich man könnte
ihnen ja auch nicht verbieten für
gazprom zu arbeiten wenn sie sich jetzt
nach der sendung entscheidender moskau
zu ziehen und für gazprom zu arbeiten
ist dass ihr recht was aber man
politisch entscheiden kann ist dass sie
nicht auch noch gelder von herrn steuer
gemäß sanktionen gegen russland warum
soll das als sanktionen nicht möglich
sei natürlich ist das möglich es ist
sehr viel möglich auch dass es ist eine
form von schröders unterstützung für das
kriegführen russland das kann man
verbieten ich vermute mal das ja auch
deshalb so loyal an putin hängt weil er
seinen fehler einfach nicht eingestehen
will und weil im putin adoptivkinder
besorgt hat spielt in seinem leben eine
große rolle nehmen wir eben die
entscheidung ab verbieten ausschluss
vergesst schröder eine darf nicht mehr
für russland auch eine eine
eine frage dazu die mich interessiert
weil mich das ganze auch sehr
beschäftigt hat obwohl ich hier bin habe
ich mit gerd schröder sozusagen
politisch aufgewachsen bin ich von da an
für politik interessiert habe als der
kanzler wurde kurz zuvor
und wenn man sich überlegt was das ganze
jetzt für ihn bedeutet er wurde bei
borussia dortmund
wurde ihm glaube ich die mitgliedschaft
entzogen er kriegt den druck bei der spd
da muss man ja eine sache auch noch
wissen lars klingbeil und gerd schröder
waren einmal engst befreundet bis vor
wenigen wochen bis dieser krieg
ausgebrochen ist bzw eskaliert ist lars
klingbeil hat man bei gerd schröder im
büro gearbeitet gerhard schröder hat in
diesem bundestagswahlkampf
wahlkampf gemacht und so weiter und so
fort auch dass ein zerwürfnis er ist bei
ringier ausgeflogen er steht in der
öffentlichkeit als buhmann da diejenigen
die ihn vorher noch verteidigt haben
haben sich abgewendet spätestens seitdem
wladimir putin hier zivilisten in der
ukraine bombardiert warum macht er das
wirklich ich frage mich mittlerweile hat
vladimir putin und damit will ich gern
schröder nicht in schutz nehmen aber ich
frage mich das hat wladimir putin
irgendetwas gegen ihn in der hand denn
ansonsten macht das doch für einen
politisch denkende mensch auch wenn er
da glauben sollte dass er irgendwie
wladimir putin markt warum auch immer ja
ich meine das ist ein kriegsverbrecher
aber es würde doch ist logisch spricht
nichts mehr dafür dass gerhard schröder
weiter daran festhält vielleicht jörges
erkennt den wahrscheinlich am längsten
ich habe ja schon gesagt ich vermute
dass hinter seiner anhaltenden loyalität
zu putin auch die kinderfrage steckt er
sich wahnsinnig persönlich nahe und er
ist ein typ der einfach fehler nicht
eingestehen kann er hat nie einen fehler
eingestanden er bringt es nicht fertig
das muss man ihm abnehmen man muss ihn
da rausholen verbieten und dann in
hannover wo er lebt vergessen dann soll
er sich überlegen wann er zurückkommt in
die öffentlichkeit mit welcher erklärung
aber jedenfalls dass die spd nun appelle
an ihn richtet finde ich völlig daneben
die spd soll dafür sorgen dass das nicht
mehr tun darf aber und darauf kommt mir
persönlich enttäuscht ich unserem tisch
gegenüber zum beispiel da warst du ja
gar nicht so stark gegen schröder wie es
jetzt beispielsweise schon vor wochen
war es ist auch eine persönliche
enttäuschung niemanden lange ich bin
auch sehr persönlich enttäuscht von
russland das werde ich gleich noch
erläutern meine position hat sich in
vielen fragen verändert auch direkt auch
meine meinung meine position zu waffen
zu waffenlieferungen ich bin 100 prozent
davon überzeugt dass die ukraine
wirklich wirksame waffen aus dem westen
kriegen muss und nicht nur kleines gerät
das ist immer noch völlig hinter der
zeit her ich will folgendes sagen lasst
uns direkt in einem jahr habe ich sehe
nur einen ausweg aus der situation
ich habe in den letzten tagen mehrfach
diskussionen erlebt es immer um die
frage gehen wie können wir wieder im
gespräch mit putin kommen und was können
wir ihnen anbieten meine antwort lautet
nichts die gespräche mit putin sind zu
ende putin muss gestürzt werden durch
einen putsch in moskau und dafür muss
der westen die voraussetzungen schaffen
durch die schärfsten denkbaren
sanktionen die man überhaupt verhängen
kann davon sind wir noch weit entfernt
damit die macht elite in moskau brüchig
wird und sich überlegt wie lange sie
noch loyal mit putin ist und damit sich
dann dinge in gang setzen die wir die
mit dem untergang putins enden drei
punkte will ich in den ersten wir
sollten sofort in import von gas öl und
kohle aus russland einstellen sofort die
eu-kommission hat schon vor tagen
errechnet dass diese importe zu
kompensieren werden aus anderen quellen
da werden die energiepreise steigen aber
dieses land ist reich genug um einen
sozialen ausgleich für ermessen zu
finden das topping zweiter punkt
es ist ja nur ein kleiner teil der
russischen banken von dem bankensystem
swiss ausgeschlossen es ist ein viertel
man glaubt es gar nicht und der westen
tut so als seien es fast alle ein
viertel ist ausgeschlossen unter anderem
ist die gazprombank immer noch in diesem
system und zwar deshalb weil die
deutschen für ihre energie importe gerne
über die gussform geschäfte mit russland
machen dafür kann ich mich nur schemen
ich finde es empörend und ich muss sagen
es ist der gipfel der verlogenheit dass
wir auf der einen seite waffen an die
ukraine liefern und auf der anderen
seite mit deutschen öl und gas geld die
russische kriegsmaschine geschmiert wird
das kann doch wohl nicht im ernst sein
wir müssen uns dafür eine seite
entscheiden und die eine seite jetzt in
diesem krieg ist die ukraine dritter
punkt ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir
zu einem generellen
handelsembargo geschäfts embargo mit
russland übergehen sollte keine importe
mehr keine exporte mehr russland total
isoliert und es gibt große deutsche
unternehmen die schon vorangehen die
autokonzerne liefern keine autos mehr
nach russland siemens hat beschlossen
russland zu verlassen und keine aufträge
von dort mehr entgegen zu nehmen das ist
der richtige weg und das nur das bringt
glaube ich menschen in russland in im
militär in den geheimdiensten dazu über
die frage nachzudenken ob sie nicht
besser putin abräumen müssten um irland
vor schweren schaden zu bewahren und
falls putin als das passiert und putin
hinterher noch lebt dann muss der westen
darauf bestehen dass er nach den haag
ausgeliefert wird an den internationalen
gerichtshof der dort kriegsverbrechen
und angriffskriege
behandelt wie er das schon gegen
serbische kriegsverbrecher getan hat
jedenfalls bin ich der meinung kein
zurück zu putin putin muss weg
pauli ich kann nur sagen so
schwierig die lage jedoch ist unsere
dramatisch die lage ist finde ich freue
ich mich dass du jetzt auch bei der
ukraine politik auf den richtigen weg
gefunden hast auch wenn es ein bisschen
gedauert hat leider kein
einfaches
ja ja ja nein es ist es ist es ist nur
sozusagen auch symbolisch ein bisschen
da wir haben ja viel über russland und
die ukraine in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten immer wieder gestritten ich
frage mich halt was wäre passiert und
auch diese frage muss man glaube ich mal
erörtern wenn du wenn andere wenn viele
politiker schon früher in diese richtung
gedacht hätten ob es dann sozusagen
diese katastrophe nicht gegeben hätte
und gleichzeitig frage ich mich
gibt es überhaupt eine chance dass das
so passiert wie du sagst also dass
wladimir putin wirklich stürzen kann da
bin ich unsicher weil ich glaube dass
sozusagen alle generäle um ihn herum
alle geheimdienstler all diejenigen die
ihn die er groß gemacht hat große sorge
haben mit ihm zusammen zu stürzen und
das bedeutet dass der geheimdienst
bereich dass der militärbereich um ihn
herum ein interesse daran hat dass er
bleibt und ich sehe dass es das glaube
ich tragische
und wenn wir sehen dass selbst auch
oligarchen
was man zumindest liest natürlich
unglücklich sind darüber wie es verläuft
aber es nicht schaffen werden ihn zu
stürzen muss man davon ausgehen dass er
bleibt und wenn wir die rede hören über
die wir vielleicht gleich auch noch
sprechen können oder die ansprache die
er gehalten hat dann muss an das
wirklich erschaudern lassen und
tatsächlich zittern lassen davor was er
noch mit der ukraine vor lieber als auch
mit welcher lieber pauli kein italy
tätig teile dein
bedenken zum teil ich stelle aber fest
es ist völlig unmöglich dass die ukraine
den krieg gegen russland gewinnt das
sind die größten velten ist einfach zu
stark das heißt da muss der westen eine
entscheidende rolle spielen ich gebe dir
zu dass ich mich in der politik
russlands und putins getäuscht habe ich
dachte es geht in wahrheit um die ost
erweiterung der nato da hat der westen
1990 nach der deutschen
wiedervereinigung fehler gemacht da hat
er russland getäuscht aber heute bin ich
froh dass es die ost erweiterung
überhaupt gegeben hat denn sonst wären
diese länder
russland im prinzip ausgeliefert auch
also ich habe erkannt dass die
argumentation mit dem namen lieber nicht
in frage stellen könne ja mach mal eine
frage weil beides gerade ansprichst weil
ich ja vorhin auch über die rede von den
oder meine die antwort von präsidentin
lenski auf meine frage gesprochen hat
hältst du es denn für völlig
unrealistisch dass selensky dass dieser
schritt ist lange putin am ende wird er
mit der ukraine fertig ist nicht
tatsächlich nach nato staaten greifen
wird also wer sagt denn dass die nato
wirklich bereit steht wenn dann ein
vermeintlich kleines land wie es also in
den baltischen staaten angegriffen
werden würde das glaube ich nicht und
ich will das auch begründen er hat doch
inzwischen mehrfach programmatisch
erklärungen abgegeben ich glaube dass er
eher denkt ehemaligen staaten der
sowjetunion wieder zurückzuerobern das
fängt an mit georgien und das ist nicht
mitglied der nato und ginge dann
theoretisch weiter in missel
mittelasiatischen staaten an den
baltischen staaten glaube ich weder sich
nicht vergreifen weil er eben scheut
davor
sich mit der nato anzulegen auch dass
die ukrainische grenze nach westen von
russischen truppen nicht abgeriegelt
wird ist ja ein zeichen dafür dass er
dort mit der nato nicht in konflikt
geraten will er will eben auch über
leben und das müssen wir eben glaube ich
durch andere mittel davon habe ich
gesprochen unmöglich machen er darf
keinen zweiten krieg führen und da darf
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen er muss
untergehen und wenn er nicht und wenn er
nicht sozusagen lebend ausgeschaltet
wird dann muss eben einer im im moskauer
machtsystem eine pistole nehmen und der
sache ein ende wir machen aus dem einzel
von euch beiden mal einen sockel und
gern mal wieder rüber zur blossen hennig
hennig wenn sie das hören die frage die
sich natürlich auch sehr sehr viele
europäer stellen ist wird die ukraine
wladimir putin überhaupt reichen wenn er
sie erobert hat
ich kann die meinung von herrn joos in
dieser frage also nicht teil in dem
sinne dass die ukraine diesen kampf
verlieren kann so sie darf ihn nicht
verlieren denn wenn wenn wenn das
geschieht dann wird es keine ukraine
geben dann ihm geht es nicht nur um
umbesetzung von von gebieten ihm geht um
dass das zerschlagen der staatlichkeit
und nutzer völlig und deswegen wir
wissen davon und egal welche
zugeständnisse jetzt von uns verlangt
oder was uns nahegelegt wird auch hier
in berlin dann man sollte sich bewegen
da ist die frage die die antwort es gibt
nichts was büdchen zufriedenstellen
würde damit er loslässt und deswegen so
vielleicht um das thema rasch
abzuschließen wir hätten für ihn und
alle beleidigungen also das bleibt in
der vergangenheit auch für uns aber er
hätte vielleicht doch eine letzte
aufgabe also er ist einer der wenigen
hier in deutschland oder vielleicht der
vielen politiker die womöglich noch
einen direkten draht zu hören guten
nacht also es gibt keinen den ukrainern
der sowas hat und/oder in anderen
europäischen ländern er könnte das
vielleicht versuchen und dann werden
wenn es ihm gelingt herrn putin das
klingt natürlich jetzt nicht sehr
realistisch aber dann würde doch
vielleicht in die geschichte nicht
eingehen als als putin lob ist und
jemand der diesen krieg vielleicht auch
herbeigeführt hat durch seinen handeln
und es geht auch darum dass dass die
politik hier auch reinen tisch macht es
gibt nicht nur herrn schröder es gibt
viele andere baganz benötigt anderem
eine
ganzjährig einer frage ab ob die reise
nach der heirat das zu vermitteln
heißt dass der botschafter dass sie
wollen dass gerd schröder vermittler wir
zwischen dem westen und russland das ist
ja eine sehr spannende forderung das ist
nur ein kreativer vor stark herunter das
liegt daran schritte wo er jetzt in
dieser position ist wo sich alle von
ihnen verabschieden und abwenden warum
dann nicht also wir müssen jede chance
nutzen und das meine ich ernst ich
glaube nicht dass es etwas zu vermitteln
gibt im ernst putin will die ukraine
erobern und russland einverleiben und
was sollte die kompromiss position sein
ein bisschen erobern anni lenz geben amt
lassen nur die ost ukraine nehmen die
krim behalten und diese und jenes das
ist ihm nicht genug das hätte er links
haben können das geht einfach nicht wir
müssen uns damit abfinden
dieser krieg den putin begonnen hat den
putin zu ende führen will bei dem er
keine zeichen von rückzug erkennen lässt
muss man gewinnen über putin man muss
putin absolvieren aber deswegen ich
werde wenn doch mal ein punkt heraus
gaben sie haben eben gesagt da die
ukraine ist verloren und da kann man
nicht mehr viel machen lassen das ist
herr jörges das halte ich für einen ganz
großen fehler das öffentlich zu sagen
misswahl das haben wir das haben wir
genau das haben wir von der woche auch
gehört paul ronzheimer ein solches laura
einmal einmal kurz aufleben lassen
ronzheimer hat das ja am anfang der
sendung auch noch einmal hervorgehoben
es gab in deutschland ich weiß dass
andere aus den diskussionen bundestag
viele die gesagt haben keine
defensivwaffen an die ukraine liefern
das wird eh nur zwei drei tage dauern
jetzt sehen wir diesen heroischen kampf
des ukrainischen volkes und wir sehen
die brauchen weitere unterstützung wir
brauchen weitere waffen wenn die jetzt
aber von uns hören na ja eigentlich sind
die schon verloren und las vielleicht
den putin sogar da mal machen aber wir
gucken dass der dann nicht weitermacht
dann wäre das ein ganz ganz schlechtes
signal zumal putin ja nicht nur die
ukraine angreift sondern ergreift damit
auch unsere demokratischen werte an
haben ergreift unsere freiheit an und er
wird sich damit möglicherweise nicht
zufriedengeben wollen wir retten wir
hätten wir uns vor drei wochen hier in
der sendung getroffen hätten sie und
andere wahrscheinlich gesagt na putin
wird ihn aktiv einmarschieren das wird
ja gar nicht warten sondern da hätten
viele gesagt na ja vielleicht in die
hand sondern immer noch was hinaus haben
viele gesagt so und jetzt sehen wir was
putin alles macht und wir wissen aus der
geschichte solche diktatoren solcher
autokraten solche verrückten die machen
meistens nicht nur bei einem land hat
und deswegen müssen wir eine stärke
entwickeln und wir müssen mehr ins
militär investiert wir müssen die
ukraine jetzt unterstützt und mir da ist
jetzt vortragen ich habe nichts anderes
gesagt ich meinte damit natürlich kann
putin militärisch die ukraine setzen
wenn er mit einem so guten eindruck hat
sie alleine nicht weil er wird immer auf
widerstand stößt es wird immer wegen der
besetzung geben
haben erstmals für sie aber mitnehmen
die die die genau die situationen hier
gerade in diesem moment nach langer ruhe
wieder sirenenalarm zumindest gerade
einmal hier
jetzt hören sie sich lassen immer leise
so hat sich der sirenenalarm in kiew an
das was wir auch schon vor zwei tagen
gehört haben also das ist die realität
für die bevölkerung hier jeden tag
insbesondere dann wenn es dunkel wird
ich habe schon mal erklärt wir haben ein
weiteres sicherheitssystem ausgestattet
auch mit apps ähnlich wie in israel wo
gewarnt wird von luftschlägen von daher
gehen wir beim ich sage mal
einfacheren
luftalarm noch nicht in den bunker
sondern warten ein bisschen aber ich
glaube diese stimmung muss man einmal
verstehen die wirklich grauenhaft ist
für die menschen hier ich möchte herrn
flossen berechnung von ein paar geben
wir ganz kurz in hier in eine ganz kurze
unterbrechung lassen auch noch mal die
sirenen nachhaltig auf uns wirken und
hoffen dass paul denn auch gleich uns
noch zugeschaltet ist und das
selbstverständlich nicht zu einem
zweiten alarm compal bis gleich
[Musik]
bild
dort bei bild sonntags die richtigen
fragen
dienstag bis donnerstag viertel nach
acht
montag und freitag live ist live
und eine der längsten und gefährlichste
operation in der geschichte der
bundeswehr
bild
wir sind zurück bei vielen nach acht
nach einer kurzen unterbrechung und wir
sind auch alle noch davor der werbung
gingen bei pforzheimer live in kiew das
erste mal die sirenen an der erste alarm
bis zum zweiten wird er aber bei uns in
der sendung bleiben der hoffentlich
nicht eintreten wird er das hoffen wir
ja alle ganz fest jetzt gehen wir aber
erstmal zum ukrainischen botschafter
andrej melik der heute ein versorgungs
korridor gefordert hat und ich würde
gerne wissen helmig was hat es denn
damit auf sicht was für ein konzept
steckt dahinter ja wir versuchen seit
den letzten tagen auch die ampel
regierung davon zu überzeugen dass wir
jetzt dringend nicht nur die frage der
waffenlieferungen auf den tisch legen
und schauen dass wir nicht nur mit
diesen kleineren geräten also anti
panzer raketen dass die ukraine aus
gestartet werden sondern dass man auch
dass das schwere gerät und liefert das
was jetzt auf lager ist das was jetzt
nicht gebraucht wird in deutschland oder
in den nächsten wochen aber wir brauchen
auch für die menschen vor ort die jetzt
seit sieben tagen gar nicht die keller
verlassen konnten weil der beschuss
ununterbrochen
keine lebensmittel mehr da sind wir
haben gesehen diese bilder die paul
ronzheimer gerade heute gefilmt hat in
einem supermarkt in kiew das heißt da
müssen wir auch dringend ein konzept
erstellen nicht nur vielleicht mit
deutschen dafür deutschland könnte da
eine wichtige rolle spielen über polen
einen langen weg damit die städte
versorgt werden kraftstoff fehlt
lebensmitteln medizin also da sollte
koordiniert werden und ich glaube dass
die handball regierung aber auch die
bundesrepublik als solcher auch die
landesregierungen sind da glaube ich in
der pflicht zur schaffung zu helfen weil
das was er getan werden kann und heute
hatte ich eine schalte mit mit einem mit
ihrem kollegen axel müller aus
ravensburg und und da gab es schon ideen
also was kann man da machen vielleicht
pulver nahrung dass das schnell
geliefert werden kann damit die menschen
dann quasi mit dem was sie haben vor ort
versorgt werden können das heißt diese
idee liegt auf dem tisch und wir hoffen
dass die bundesregierung das die politik
dass die menschen auch dieses konzept
unterstützen denn es geht um tod oder
leben von von vielen zivilisten die
einfach unter beschuss leben müssen und
aushalten müssen
inwiefern gerade wünschen angesprochen
christoph dein kollege was hältst du von
diesem versorgungs korridor wie schätzt
du es ein muss deutschland jetzt gerade
mithelfen vorgehen aber vielleicht auch
wir die ganzen europäischen ländern
zusammen das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger
punkt gleich auf der einen seite reden
wir über waffenlieferungen damit sich
das ukrainische volk verteidigen kann
aber auf der anderen seite müssen wir
natürlich auch diese humanitäre
katastrophe im blick haben und die
vielen unschuldigen zivilisten die davon
betroffen sind deswegen da gibt denke
ich gar nicht weil meinungen dass das
absolut unterstützenswert ist ich will
noch mal einen hinweis nur geben wir als
cdu zum beispiel in hamburg und auch
viele kollegen in ganz deutschland die
unterstützen solche initiativen und sind
auch in gesprächen mit der ukrainischen
diaspora vor ort und helfen wo man
helfen kann aber es ist häufig
sinnvoller dass auch über
hilfsorganisationen zu machen die auch
eine große expertise haben als dass
jetzt jeder einzeln versucht irgendwie
ein paar sachen zu sammeln und die dann
vielleicht sogar selber irgendwo
hinzubringen sondern da wirklich auch
sehr stark auf die hilfsorganisation zu
setzen als an laut dass es sieht ja das
beispiel auf instagram die menschen dann
dort selber an die grenze fahren um das
zu tun ist da nicht vielleicht bringt es
mehr bei einer hilfsorganisation aber
ist das als symbol nicht viel mehr was
uns alle miteinander vereint wenn man
geld nun schaffen das ist ja auch super
man muss das auch immer im einzelfall
sich anschauen das kann man jetzt schwer
pauschal sagen aber es gibt ja ganz
viele in deutschland die fragen sich wo
kann ich helfen und wie kann ich helfen
und was mache ich am besten und da gibt
es unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
manchmal ist es tatsächlich auch
sinnvoll eine geldspende zu tätigen weil
man weiß dann kommt das ganz schnell
auch an und es gibt auch profis die sich
darum kümmern dass das schnell zu den
ukrainischen menschen kommt als dass man
jetzt selber versucht so eine logistik
aufzubauen ich wollte nur einmal diesen
hinweis geben weil nicht viele
tatsächlich auch aus sehr guten motiven
sagen ach ich versuche jetzt selber das
irgendwie dahin zu bringen und das ist
nicht immer sinnvoll also die
hilfsorganisation die haben natürlich
eine sehr große expertise und erfahrung
ich möchte gerne drei fragen an sie
stellen die sie ganz einfach beantworten
können ohne lange erklärungen erstens
sind sie dafür alle energie importe aus
russland zu beenden zweitens bin ich da
hin sie dafür alle russischen banken aus
trifft auszuschließen ja sehr gut
drittens sind sie dafür ein
handelsembargo gegen russland zu
verhängen wenn ich auch sehr dafür ich
glaube die die aktuellen maßnahmen die
reichen noch nicht aus und wir brauchen
dafür hat das ist ja das ist also ich
bin genau wie sie der meinung herr
jörges eben haben wir hart gestritten
aber hier hier teile ich ihre meinung
russland muss isoliert werden russland
muss noch viel stärker mit sanktionen
belastet werden wir brauchen ein
umfassendes handelsembargo weil nur wenn
russland das richtig spürt und russland
auch kaum mehr die möglichkeit hat gas
und öl irgendwo hin zu verkaufen dann
wird es dort zu einem umdenken kommen
und wenn wir sagen na ja wir wollen doch
noch ein bisschen gas beziehen und ein
bisschen kohle und auch ein bisschen öl
dann ist das nicht zielführend weil es
immer noch dazu führt dass russland
genügend gelder im staatshaushalt und
dann auch gut überleben kann während ist
gleichzeitig das indische volk ihr
gewissen
die fernseh gerne vorschläge man hat
endlich begonnen auch die akten von von
superreichen hier in deutschland zu
beschlagnahmen das hätte man vor vier
jahren tun müssen und mein vorschlag ist
dass man sofort das was man hat in der
hand dass der deutsche staat verkauft
und dafür auch die menschen in der
ukraine und auch der wiederaufbau in der
ukraine schon heute beginnen sollte
finanziert werden kann das ist auch die
idee dass auch die in die konten der
zentralbank russlands oder von anderen
banken das dass das muss alles
beschränkt beschlagnahmt werden nicht
nur jetzt eingefroren oder es muss ein
verfahren gefunden werden damit man
wirklich diejenigen trifft und nicht nur
trifft sondern wirklich das geld von
ihnen wegnimmt und das geld sofort
wieder um den menschen die jetzt da sind
und leiden zu helfen henning ich
verstehe dass nun auch ich bin für
sanktionen gegenüber russland ganz klar
aber manchmal frage ich mich auch wir
haben uns zu lange aber das hat
deutschland getan von einem despoten
energietechnisch abhängig gemacht das
ist so herr beck hat heute ja auch noch
mal gesagt dass wir energietechnisch
schon abhängig sind der ist jetzt meine
frage der natürlich auch an dich wie
wollen wir das jetzt so schnell umsetzen
also wir sagen wir sanktionieren
russland mit allem wie machen wir das
mit der energie in deutschland gut es
gibt ja auch die möglichkeit auf lng
terminal zu setzen aus meiner sicht muss
auch die kernkraft eine option bleiben
über das jahr hinaus wir müssen auch
über das thema kohle noch mal reden und
gucken dass wir mit partnern wie den usa
aber auch in
arabischen bereich versuchen das ende
gasen aus das problem ist das sagen und
das ist in amerika ist das problem es
wird sich der gaspreis seien vermutlich
verdoppeln weiß torwart ins aber das ist
das ist ein anschein habe ich noch mal
dass aufgaben was herr jörges sagt
natürlich werden ganz harte sanktionen
wird ein umfassendes handelsembargo auch
uns treffen und wir werden das in den
preisen merken aber es ist doch nur
glaubwürdig wenn wir nicht sagen sobald
es uns irgendwo auch selber berührt
lassen wir das und dann soll was ihnen
lieber weiter geld bekommen um das
ukrainische volk zu holen muss um das
kann das kann nicht der ansatz sein aber
da muss und staat zahlen soll daher nach
der staat dann gucken wir gerade die
marien und diejenigen die das wirklich
auf finanziell hart trifft unterstützt
da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten mit einmalzahlung mit
steuersenkungen das hat man so komisch
der vergleich jetzt vielleicht erst mal
klingen mag aber wenn der korona krise
haben wir gezeigt wie man auch dann
hilfspakete schnüren kann aber ich finde
ist völlig falsch wenn man sagt weil wir
hier selber keine einschränkung spüren
wollen kaufen wir weiterhin russisches
öl oder russisches gas und finanzieren
damit ja putins krieg das kann nicht
sein könnten glaubt werden können doch
nicht an diesem krieg auch noch
verdienen genau gehen wir von russland
subventionierte preise genießen das kann
doch wohl nicht im ernst es sein das
heißt die eu kommission hat ja schon
ausgerechnet vor einiger zeit dass die
deutschen lieferungen aus russland 55
prozent des gases 35 prozent des öls
sofort zu ersetzen wären aus anderen
quellen sofort zu höheren preisen aber
die müssen wir dann eben in kauf nehmen
und dann müssen wir sehen wie wir damit
umgehen und da müssen wir leuten die
sich die höheren energiepreise nicht
leisten können einen ersatz geben
natürlich aus der staatskasse was immer
das dann bedeutet aber jedenfalls nur so
ist eine ethisch fundierte politik in
diesem krieg überhaupt denkbar und ohne
und ganz wichtig es nur einige
lebenslügen über bord geworfen werden
also wenn ich ihr habt mit den grünen ja
viele diskussionen gehabt die haben wir
gesagt die kernkraft geht gar nicht da
müssen wir raus aus kohle müssen wir
sofort raus auch das muss man
hinterfragen denn wir werden nur eine
grundlast kapazität in der
energiepolitik bekommen wenn wir auch
jenseits der erneuerbaren option haben
und deswegen glaube ich müssen wir auch
die debatte über kernkraft neu in
deutschland führen und wahrscheinlich
brauchen wir auch über dieses jahr
hinaus kernenergie in deutschland die
runde ist sich eine karte sanktionen für
russland ich bin mir sicher dass du die
meinung auch teils deswegen kann ich
sagen die runde ist sich einig
oder siehst du das anders ist glaube ich
aber nicht nein das haben wir jetzt hier
schon mal gesagt und es war das zweite
leidenschaftlichen plädoyer von herr
plus für die kernenergie das würde jetzt
auch für den nutzen gestern gab es schon
1 ich glaube das hat deutschland in den
letzten jahren nicht gedacht dass man
das hier mal erleben wird in deutschen
talkshows und somit kommen wir zum
letzten thema für heute abend und zwar
zu dem von cdu politiker
die schlimmen ereignisse in der ukraine
und der angriffskrieg von wladimir putin
und von russland auf das ukrainische
volk die sind nicht nur für hering in
der ukraine und sie stellen eine
belastung für ganz europa dar sondern
sie werfen natürlich auch in deutschland
viele neue fragen auf und eine der
fragen ist brauchen wir die wehrpflicht
oder müssen wir auch in deutschland
wieder die wehrpflicht einführen und ich
bin der meinung wir brauchen nicht eine
wehrpflicht wie wir sie früher
kennengelernt haben aber wir brauchen
eine allgemeine dienstpflicht oder ein
gesellschafts jahr in deutschland das
für männer und das für frauen
gleichermaßen gilt jeder junge mensch
der sollte nach der schule entweder zur
bundeswehr gehen der sollte wie früher
beim zivildienst vielleicht in ein
pflegeheim gehen der sollte in eine
einrichtung gehen wo menschen mit
behinderungen und menschen mit
behinderung geholfen wird wo es ihnen
ermöglicht wird ins alltagsleben im
alltagsleben fuß zu fassen es kann sein
dass es gut ist dass menschen in eine
erziehungsanstalt gehen es gibt ganz
viele soziale einrichtungen im land in
denen gerade junge menschen gebraucht
werden und wo es auch gut ist dass junge
menschen mal rauskommen aus dem was sie
sonst so kenne das sie mit sozialen
problemen konfrontiert werden und
deswegen bin ich dafür wir brauchen mehr
staatsbürger und wir brauchen weniger
ich bürger in deutschland und ist kann
für den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
enorm hilfreich sein wenn menschen nach
dem schulabschluss ein gesellschafts
jahr machen und etwas im sozialen
bereich tun oder auch zur bundeswehr
gehen
brauchen weniger ich bürger wir brauchen
mehr staatsbürger das höre ich in
deutschland in der korona pandemie seit
zwei jahren in dauerschleife ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich möchte dass der
ukraine geholfen wird und zwar zu dem
höchst möglichen maße ich bewundere
hennig der heute in der runde ist wie
sehr er kämpft für sein land und auch
ich will dass deutschland hilft
sanktionen gehören dazu aber jetzt schon
wieder ist die jungen leute schon wieder
entscheidet der staat was junge leute in
deutschland machen sollen das reicht und
ich ja aber auch nicht ich würde die
fragen direkt an hennig schicken dass es
ihrem land jetzt hilft wenn wir in
deutschland ein gesellschafts jahr
machen und nach der korona pandemie wie
der jungen menschen vorschreiben was sie
jetzt karabey zu tun haben oder wie
sehen von der st das ist aber an herrn
melden ich glaube dass der gedanke schon
richtig ist das denn doch bloß gerade
ausgedrückt hat denn wir brauchen schon
wir haben gesehen also der staat hat
einen wert und das erleben wir mit
grüner denn ohne staat haben wir viele
jahrzehnte verbringen müssen ohne den
staat und das heißt den wert dieses
staates zu erkennen was das auch für
jeden einzelnen bürger bedeutet das hat
man das sieht man jetzt in der ukraine
man kämpft ja nicht nur für für den
wohnblock wurde für das dorf sondern
auch für diesen ukrainische staat weil
wenn es ihnen nicht geben sollte dann
ist das alles weg dann kann man alles
vergessen kann man den wohlstand nicht
mehr haben dann kann man die sprache
vergessen das alles wird verschwinden
und deswegen ich kann durchaus diese
meinung teilen ich bürger ist wichtig
freiheit wir sind wir eben auch freiheit
aber neben der freiheit ist die
staatlichkeit aus unserer sicht genauso
zentral ich war früher exakt derselben
meinung wie sie ich habe dafür auch
mehrfach geschrieben weil mir das sehr
einleuchtend erschienen heute bin ich
nicht mehr dieser meinung jedenfalls
nicht mehr vollständig weil ich glaube
dass ein soziales pflichtjahr für junge
leute im sozialen bereich den druck auf
die gehälter die niedrigen gehälter für
die leute die dort fest arbeiten noch
verstärken wird wenn die die
krankenhäuser die soziale einrichtungen
quasi kostenfrei junge leute kriegen
bedeutet das dass die leute die dort
arbeiten in keine richtung argumente
mehr haben um ihre gehälter zu
verbessern ich glaube um es kurz zu
machen
dass wir die wehr
die davon überzeugt dass es richtig war
die wehrpflicht hat eine große
politische tradition nämlich das kann
man heute kaum mehr sagen ohne falsch
verstanden zu werden das war als sie
geschaffen wurde wurde vom milizsystem
gekaufter
milizionäre abstand genommen und es
wurde eine volksarmee eingeführt die hat
beispielsweise dazu beigetragen napoleon
aus aus aus aus mittel und osteuropa zu
vertreiben nur so war das mögliche sind
preußen eingeführt worden und war eine
politische errungenschaft und diese
politische errungenschaft dass alle sich
für den staat und seine sicherheit
einzusetzen haben ist leichtfertig von
der cdu aufgegeben worden da haben viele
schon damals daran gezweifelt und heute
sind die zweifel noch viel größer
geworden die bundeswehr hatte damals als
es die wehrpflicht noch gab doppelt so
viele soldaten wie sie heute hat und
heute mangels ja nicht nur an gerät es
mangelt auch an menschen die in der
bundeswehr dienen und deshalb ich stimme
ihnen also partiell zu über den rest
müsste man auch reden wehrpflicht wieder
her aber da will ich dann will ich mal
widersprechen weil wir haben ja kein
problem die ganz dass die ganz vielen
offenen stellen die es ja im gerade im
pflegebereich gibt zu besetzen also es
würde ja nicht dazu führen wenn jetzt
ein junger mensch in bereichen der zahlt
wenn es ein wenn jetzt ein junger mensch
im bereich der pflege hilft wird das nie
dazu führen dass eine ausgebildete
pflegekraft keinen job bekommt sondern
das gegenteil ist der fall wir haben ja
hunderttausende offene stellen schon
klar und ein junger mensch der nach der
schule beispielsweise bei der pflege
hilft der macht ja nicht genau das was
eine ausgebildete pfleger macht das darf
der ja gar nicht deswegen kann man das
auch nicht so vergleichen mir geht es
eher darum dass man einfach mal mit
problemen dieses landes konfrontiert
wird dass junge menschen die vielleicht
sonst behütet aufwachsen danach ein
studium machen in einem büro sitzen im
glaskasten danach ihren porsche nach
hause fahren dass die auch einen anderen
bereich mal sehen und auch mit anderen
menschen zusammen kommen mit denen sie
sonst vielleicht nie zusammen kommen
würden und das ist für den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt ganz
ganz wichtig und es gibt im land so viel
bedarf an sozialen tätigkeiten dass das
argument da wird kann vielleicht eine
pflegekraft dann nicht mehr arbeiten
einfach nicht gilt wir werden da nach
der sendung bestimmt wird immerhin das
dann ausgegeben ich möchte aber die
letzten zwei seine minuten nutzen um
noch einen eindruck vom pforzheimer aus
der ukraine zu haben heute bei der achte
kriegstag paul und vielleicht eine
minute lang kannst du noch mal die
eindrücke schildern vielleicht auch für
zuschauer die er später eingeschaltet
haben
ja also der sirenenalarm ist wieder weg
tatsächlich war es heute vergleichsweise
ruhig tagsüber was sicherlich mit den
vermeintlichen friedensgesprächen zu tun
gehabt hat nur da darf man sich leider
nichts vormachen das ist die taktik die
wladimir putin auch schon in syrien
benutzt hat er nutzt friedensgespräche
um zu sagen schaut her ich will ja
keinen krieg gegen die zivilisten führen
und dann wenige tage später nutzte er
das als begründung um zu sagen dass alle
die jetzt noch im kessel von kiew sind
sozusagen feinde sind nazis sind und das
ist das was er rhetorisch vorbereitet
deswegen müssen wir davon ausgehen dass
die schweren waffen die schon in anderen
teilen des landes eingesetzt werden
jetzt auch bald in kiew eingesetzt
werden ich habe vor einer stunde das
letzte mal mit vitali klitschko
telefoniert den bürgermeister von pia
viel bereitet man sich auf häuserkampf
am ende vor ich glaube nicht dass es zum
häuserkampf will kommt so schnell
sondern es wird zum einsatz von vielen
raketen kommen es wird möglicherweise
zur einkesselung kommen der stadt und
das bedeutet dass es dann schwierig sein
wird hier noch medizin reinzubekommen
hier noch lebensmittel reinzubekommen so
ist die traurige lage gleichzeitig
appelliere ich so ein bisschen auch an
die zuschauer und an uns alle
journalisten sozusagen nicht nur in
anführungszeichen nach kiew zu schauen
denn wir sehen das in vielen weiteren
teilen des landes und die ukraine ist
ein riesen lange zeit mit 70 millionen
dankes sendezeit ich vorbei das tut mir
leid ich danke euch
pass auf dich auf pass auf dich auf paul
danke mach ich danke schön für deine
arbeit bis morgen abend wieder dann sind
wir wieder hier bei vielen nach acht
hall und ich werde auch morgen abend
wieder da sein um 20 15 schönen abend
noch
[Musik]